todos los asistentes están en modo de solo escucha que tal muy buenas tardes
bienvenidos a la que creo que es la séptima clase del curso de trading
algoritmico a ver jose me decía y que no me oye antes pero es que todavía no
había abierto a ver si ahora todo el mundo me oye ahora sí vale a ver todo
el mundo oye pregunto si no todo el mundo oye escribo porque es el que no me
oye esto es una aquí no puedo escribir si pero el que no me oye no puede
contestar pili el que no me oye no puede contestar ese es un típica es una una
típica es preguntar al que te oye si te está oyendo es evidente que te oye el
que no te oye le tienes que escribir porque si no no te no te oye es es es
de parabolitos de streaming bueno pues vamos allá vamos allá venga vamos a
empezar como los últimos días con las consultas que nos hacéis llegar y que
creo que son interesantes para todos había bastante
había bastante movimiento por aquí antes bueno creo que lo he visto por
aquí he visto antes en tu mensaje pues la verdad que no lo sé porque sí que
nosotros tenemos una nos está mirando ves aquí ahora se está viendo aquí en
configuraciones salen las las cosas pero
no ha salido esa sabes no ha salido esa ha salido una de hace más días que es
esto no de warning de lo que os decía ves dupliqué de text no sé si llega a
ver pero ahí lo pone pero por ejemplo de hoy no sale no sé no sé no sé decirte
este es el log el bot que creo que te debe bloquear que es el m6 y no sé
por qué aquí no sale aquí no sale el aviso el aviso de bloqueado no aquí hay
este que te decía no pero estos del 22 o me he dado cuenta después de decirte
que esto es de hace un montón de días entonces no sé dónde mirarlo así que
pues no sé no sé decirte porque es que esto de este bot no se instala y sin más
supongo que sí que se debe configurar algo pero hemos tocado nada de manera de
manera consciente así que no sé por ahora si no si quieres enviar algo
enviarnoslo a nosotros o no sé no sé qué decirte porque ya digo no sé cómo
evitar que te que te bloquee que decía estoy aquí hablando y sólo me estará
entendiendo él no se había puesto un mensaje que le bloqueaba no en el
discord bloqueaba por aquí lo pone su vida fallida porque dice que los
propietarios también lo podrán ver bueno pues ya me dirán dónde porque yo
puedo no sé dónde verlo no sé dónde verlo vale a ver por aquí teníamos
algunas cositas pendientes en principio jugaban el teatro he comentado si si
eso que no le gusta así supongo que por seguridad de bloquear el código no no
sé decirte porque enviarnos lo por email ahí fue a roba ser san sistemas
y supongo que a nosotros nos dejará digo yo que si nos dejará nosotros y ya lo
pongo yo y digo que es tuyo no hay problema es seguro que estaba todo todo
respondido juan manuel pero si hay algo bueno todo respondido todo comentado que
ya más adelante lo tocaríamos como de los cortes etcétera vale y esto que
comentase también del profit mensual y tal creo que la semana pasada ya lo
comentamos que ya más adelante en algún en algún otro sistema lo
veríamos vale también insistía al verlo en los umbrales a ver la semana
pasada creo que lo comenté también comentó como referencias y luego por
aquí a más rugate creo que también respondía a eso no pidiendo algo algo
voy por orden vale voy por orden vale es juan manuel había añadido más
preguntas vale más preguntas me las he estado mirando mirando antes bueno que
las estáis viendo me las voy a también yendo yendo le das comentaba lo mismo
respecto a umbrales mínimos y máximos de variaciones de combinaciones posibles
para una optimización a ver lo voy a intentar incidir en cuando cuando lo
lo vamos en un sistema en concreto pero no es fácil dar una referencia una
referencia o sea sí que hay una por ejemplo una referencia que solemos que
hay bastante consenso en la industria y podemos decir que el sistema debe
aceptar una variación del orden de al menos un 10% de los parámetros vale eso
se puede ser una referencia es decir de sus parámetros deben poderse mover un
10% y no destrozarse el sistema vale no esto de los sistemas sería por una
pequeña referencia que puedo que puedo darte pero es que no es posible dar una
referencia global porque es que no claro o sea primero que todos los parámetros
son muy distintos y es depende por eso trataremos de ver sistemas de todo tipo
y os animo a en cada caso por ir preguntando para ir cogiendo ese punto
de experiencia que es la práctica que te lo da no entonces es complicado
complicado porque ya digo varía mucho pero bueno sí que ese rango que te digo
de un 10% de variación en los inputs deberían de aceptar vale deberían de
aceptar es recordar que lo comentamos en la teoría y lo voy a decir en la
práctica no todos los inputs son iguales los hay más delicados que otros depende
mucho del tipo de sistema y en un sistema por ejemplo como estamos ahora
con esto es revé intra diario donde podemos sacar trades como churros aquí
siempre hay más margen de maniobra siempre más margen de maniobra en el
sentido de que puedes darle un poco forzar un poco más a nivel de optimizar
y demás vale porque y abrir más los parámetros lo que sí que recomiendo
bastante prudencia siempre es los incrementos de acuerdo los incrementos no
pasaros de la rosca y es buena práctica mirar por ejemplo los dos aros los
tuvimos otra vez revisar si alguien estuvo el jueves en el directo comenté
que el viernes teníamos agujero para revisar a polo y está esta revisión y
de hecho estuve pensando si si si no no lógicamente todo pero si puede enseñar
algo respecto respecto a ese proceso y seguramente lo haremos lo lo tengo que
preparar un poco cuando ya lo acabemos pero pero creo que es un buen ejercicio
explicarlo explicar un poco lo sucedido tal y al final que hemos hecho de
acuerdo creo que eso es un buen ejercicio práctico vale un buen ejercicio
práctico entonces no para esta pero pero sí que lo creo que lo lo explicaré
lo explicaré porque creo que es muy bueno para para que aprendáis un
poquito la vida real del operativa bien que más decía Juan Manuel que cuando
tiene un sistema que ha pasado la evaluación preliminar quiere ver qué
salidas son óptimas tanto de stop como de tp se deben ir probando a mano varias
algunas formas sistemática o consenso sólo sobre cuáles van mejor según qué
tipo de estrategias sean por ejemplo para sistemas intradías mi reversión
funciona mejor esto plove el porcentaje y te pende de etcétera no sé si o para un
sistema tendencial long only definitiva pues si hay un cierto un cierto
consenso bueno en esto lo que te puedo decir Juan Manuel es que ya sé que me
puedes decir el sentido común no al final la teoría cuando hablamos de estos
insistía de esto es verdad es que es que es la es la realidad es verdad que el
sentido común lógicamente con la con la experiencia con la práctica pues se va se
va educando o adaptando no es digamos que la experiencia lo hace aparecer de
manera más clara o con más criterio podemos decirlo pero es cierto es cierto
que es así es decir al final
yo tengo la sensación que he hablado bastante de esto la teoría pero entiendo
que son muchas horas y que seguro que no en todas las horas estás igual de de
atento tú haciéndolo y yo mismo o sea yo estoy seguro yo claro que lo he visto un
montón de veces los vídeos pero estoy seguro que ahora mismo los volviera a ver
y diría cosas distintas y diría hostia aquí esto porque son muchas horas
grabadas no eres un robot acuerdo y al final aunque lógicamente tienes un guión
pues pues hay detalles que te van viniendo y tal y que son distintos de
cualquier cosas que seguro que no he comentado es obvio pero sí que tengo la
impresión que de esto he hablado bastante pero a ver si tú hablas por
ejemplo comentamos de con el primera estrategia que hicimos de ruptura en
acciones no al final un tendencial por ejemplo vale un tendencial puro no debe
tenerte p no debe tenerte p pero es verdad que eso lo hace degradar mucho
lo hace degradar mucho por lo tanto hay que ver hay que ver que hay que ver por
lo que os he venido comentado muchas veces que tengo yo la cartera es decir
ese es mi único sistema vale o tengo más sistemas si es mi único sistema
probablemente será mejor que tenga tp vale porque porque eso le va a hacer
mejor a los ratios le va a hacer seguramente tener menor drawdown etcétera
etcétera tienes entonces al final
todo depende es la realidad la realidad es que es así que todo depende pero sí
que es verdad que un tendencial puro debe dejar correr porque al final el
ratio de aciertos te lo dice mucho es decir tú cuando tienes un sistema con un
ratio de aciertos muy elevado vale es decir imagínate un ratio de aciertos 70
por ciento eso es un típical super mil reversión super mil reversión eso
normalmente normalmente normalmente se consigue con stops alejados o
inexistentes se entienden o inexistentes o solo stops de catastrófico no
acordaros que hablamos de eso que realmente saltan muy muy pocas veces no
apolo está en un término medio no llega a eso no llega a esos a su stop le
cuesta saltar pero pero bueno acaba acaba saltando acaba saltando vale ahí hay
situaciones peores pero es verdad que eso ya es un min reversión quiere
decir que ahí sí que lo normal es que tenga tp más o menos cercano y esto más
alejado normalmente
un min reversión que prácticamente siempre lleva tp en cuanto al tipo de
desktops yo te diría que la la primera opción para mí siempre es en
volatilidad de acuerdo siempre es ajustados por volatilidad yo os hablé un
poquito de todas las opciones pero prácticamente si pasáis a las cosas
que hemos ido diciendo pues está bastante implícito esto en todo lo que
habíamos ido diciendo no final tienes que ajustarte a los movimientos del
mercado la volatilidad te permite eso te permite eso donde sí que hay cierta
controversia en mi opinión de manera un tanto sorprendente de manera un tanto
sorprende pero la hay es en porcentual o valor absoluto de acuerdo hay bastantes
autores que defienden usar en valor absoluto esto ya te demuestra que no es
sota caballo rey de acuerdo que no esto no es sota caballo entonces
porque es porque hay es verdad que tú haces estudios haces optimizaciones y
demás y es verdad que hay veces que consigues
muchas veces mejor resultado el valor monetario que en porcentaje esto es
cierto ahora para mí esto quiere decir el tema el tema cuando vosotros estudios
y mira justamente esta semana por esa semana este mes
a ver a ver si lo encuentro rápido porque eso creció realmente quería
quería poneros lo esto porque es realmente súper interesante creo que
estas debates aunque no sea un debate al uso pero estas reflexiones creo que
aportan mucho mucho valor porque esto no lo tenía directamente aquí preparado
pero lo encuentro enseguida que es que en esto con commodities de este mes hay un
artículo justamente que me me trajo a colación todo este debate a ver si lo
si lo encuentro
acuerdas donde está esto con commodities alberto rápido no no
estoy mirando aquí donde debería creo estar a no ya sé dónde está ya sé
dónde está ya sé dónde está ya sé dónde está ya llegó ya llegó o no
llegó es ya llegó había un artículo a ver si lo aquí está sí señor sí
el bueno de andrea unger que no es un cualquiera es un cualquiera alguien con
mucho prestigio y bastante conocido bueno hace un artículo hace un debate
esto ya os lo comenté hoy tenemos materiales lo que comenté todos los
artículos bueno todo el material que tratamos de conseguir pues lo tratamos
de preparar y trabajar un poco para daros también material hoy tengo
documentos que daros luego luego los doy pero ese no lo tenía preparado pero
bueno os lo muestro aquí no bueno hacía un debate sobre esto sobre esto sobre
estar si es fixe todo un porcentaje y él ya lo suponía porque ya lo sé
nos conocemos un poco todos ya lo sé lo que piensa y también que mi por
ejemplo de evita haber hecho un artículo al respecto vale diciendo que
él ha tenido aunque le sorprende ha tenido mejores resultados en valor
absoluto que el porcentaje no lógicamente sólo es una opción no
pero no es que sea la panacea que ambos sistemas y el sistema es
bueno pues puede puede ir bien no pero pero comentaba esto no lo que pasa que
la la el tema el problema para mí es que para mi caen en un error la verdad y lo
lo tengo muy claro para mí caer en un error porque seguramente es más fácil
ajustar a los datos en valor absoluto que en porcentaje vale por distintos
motivos pero yo no tengo nada claro que eso garantice que en el futuro siga
siendo así entonces lo que no he visto a nadie o sea que un que me haga un
artículo diciendo mira hace cinco años cinco años puse el mismo sistema lo
trabajé en porcentaje y lo trabajé en valor absoluto lo puse a operar los dos
y resulta que bueno no uno no con 20 sistemas y me han ido mejor el 70 por
ciento que que he usado valor absoluto cuando vea eso entonces a mejor bueno
mejor no entonces tendré que cambiar de opinión pero pero actualmente sigo
pensando que no sigo pensando que no a pesar de estos estudios que hacen y que
yo también he hecho por supuesto y que es verdad y que pueda haber algún caso
y que en casos donde por ejemplo entre a diario donde la variación del precio
no sea tan elevada porque no vas tantos años atrás puede tener sentido pero en
realidad cuando vas a muy muy atrás para mí ya digo no tiene no tiene ningún
sentido y aunque los datos digan que da mejores ratios en mi opinión en mi
opinión no tiene sentido porque los datos demuestran que en el pasado desde
ahora mirado hacia atrás teniendo en cuenta lo que implica un backtest en sí
pues consigues mejores resultados pero no quiere decir que operándolo en ese
momento los hubieras conseguido para mí esto es bastante precipitado afirmarlo
vale bastante precipitado afirmarlo porque al final caes en un caes en detalles
tienes que poner el que es coherente en uno de los dos lados porque a lo mejor
este además creo que lo hice con equity es decir que lo ha hecho duro y por eso
que sé mil dólares por decir algo no me acuerdo cuánto ponía aquí que lo leí
la semana pasada esto se ponía mil dólares
bueno en esto aquí de porcentaje veo que pone 2% incluso la selección que hace es
un poquito
pero bueno que no digo que no lo haya hecho bien a mejor que el artículo
final no deja de ser un resumen no y tampoco va a explicar todo lo que ha hecho
porque seguramente sería muy largo no pero ya digo yo yo en general no estoy
no estoy de acuerdo que hay que investigarlo y que hay que tratar de
entenderlo pero pero no no lo compro no lo compro en sistemas sobre todo que van
en el diario que tienen mucho recorrido vale ahora bien hay que entender que si
lo ajustas a la volatilidad en valor absoluto ya es ya estás haciendo un ya
te estás ajustando la base en el fondo estás haciendo un porcentaje aunque no
lo estás haciendo directamente no sé si si me estoy explicando porque tú
realmente el problema el problema que tienes es que no es lo mismo el precio a
5.000 que el precio 10.000 lo que el precio a 2.000 entonces ese componente
el porcentaje lo tiene en cuenta pero el de volatilidad también lo tiene en
cuenta porque el rango ya te ajusta eso en el momento que tú aplicas un
multiplicador al atr eso es un porcentaje se entiende no eso es lo
mismo hacer un porcentaje de esto del club es que del valor atr que no deja
de ser un precio eso entiendo que se entiende no de lo que se entiende
entonces cuando tú ya estás haciendo haciendo volatilidad aunque realmente el
atr en sí sea un valor en puntos al multiplicarlo ya lo has hecho por
porcentaje no deja de ser un valor relativo de acuerdo no es no es magia o
sea es simplemente una manera de adaptarte relativamente a los valores
que hay no en ese momento de mercado entonces cuando haces a terrestres haciendo
porcentaje me refiero a volatilidad bien esto vería con hacer un poco de lo que
comentaba aquí juan manuel con los con los con los stops y te pesa entonces ya
te digo un mil reversión práctica un mil reversión tiene tp stop
y y a final de día o no nuevamente te digo de verdad no hay una respuesta
mágica o sea un intradía puro el otro día creo que lo comenté joan manuel en
principio debe cerrar a fin de día pero entramos un poquito en lo que te decía
porfolio es decir si tú tienes ya dos sistemas que cierran a fin de día mejor
pues te interesa uno continuo que corra porque es sólo eso le va a dar una
diversificación importante que no hay diversificación mejor que las
distintas estrategias ahora si tú empiezas y tú tienes tu primer sistema
y tú realmente tienes una cuenta pequeña a suponer y por lo tanto
necesitas un drawdown bajo pues pon tp pon esto pon salida fin de día vale
por lo todo vale por lo todo porque todas o sea todo puede ayudar a reducir
el riesgo y seguramente también la rentabilidad pero a ti te interesa sobre
todo más el riesgo de entrada entonces por lo tanto por todo por lo todo vale
por lo todo me refiero tp esto y salida fin de día
así que bueno espero haberte ayudado un poco y en cuanto a los breakouts pues
que es donde estamos ahora no es revés un breakout al final un breakout no deja
de ser un tendencial con tp porque si yo voy a salir a fin de día no tiene
sentido no tener tp jose ahí es cuando manuel perdona no tiene sentido no cerrar
a fin de día porque no tener tp porque yo voy a cerrar sí o sí
entonces hombre es pensar que siempre el mercado va a cerrar a favor de tu has
abierto la posición es pensar ser muy optimista no por lo tanto si tú ya
sabes que tienes que cerrar hombre pues ponte tp y intenta salir en una
condición mejor que habrá días que a lo mejor pues pues pues eso sea cerca del
cierre pero muchos no
vale comentaba también manuel cómo se podía programar el código para que nos
avise el plan de supervisión para ahorita temprana si esto esto sí que lo
viste es un poco la teoría pero sí que tenemos pensado
enseñar nuestro acuerdo si que tenemos pensado creo que lo preguntabas por
aquí o más adelante a esto sí que así preguntas aquí que será posible tener
el workspace de control si sí que tenéis sí que teníamos pensado entregar enseñar
lo que lo que lo que tenemos de acuerdo a nivel de estas alertas tempranas vale
pero esto prefiero hacerlo ya más avanzado es decir podéis ir preguntando
lo que queráis pero ya os dije que muchas cosas os diría ya lo veremos más
adelante porque de momento he preferido empezar a hacer 2 3 sistemas antes de
ponernos a hacer cosas específicas vale porque porque ya habíamos visto muchas
cosas específicas y pues creía que era mejor empezar así que al final no deja
ser un poco más más fresco y más dinámico que ponerse solo a ver el de
supervisión hablar de servidores o hablar de evaluar señales de entrada o
señales de salida entonces pues lo hemos montado lo hemos montado sí pero sí
que haremos esta esta parte de acuerdo está esta parte de supervisión y ahí
pues lógicamente enseñaremos enseñaremos material claro que es lo
que tenemos no podemos enseñar otra cosa vale
a ver que Juan Manuel la comento ahora porque tiene tiene relación con esto
vale si no la dejaría para el final ya sabéis pero pero como viera colación
de lo que estamos de lo que estoy comentando ahora lo comento añade Juan
Manuel que sí que si tienes bueno una duda no que si tienes un total de 10
sistemas con un capital de 100.000 si por ejemplo tenemos un sistema con un
capital asignado de 10.000 pero con 4 7 diferentes mezclamos parámetros traen
frames y activos el capital repartido entre los cuatro es 2500 por sed y cuenta
como a uno de 10 sistemas o se le asignan 10.000 a cada set como si fueran
sistemas independientes y cuenta como 4 o 10 sistemas bueno esto sí que también
creo que alguien para de personas han comentado el porfolio
los últimos días ya os comenté que sí que haremos lo que pasa que sí que
pues necesito tener 5 7 sistemas hechos vale entonces cuando hagamos entre los
que hagamos aquí y los que ya hayamos visto un poco la teoría que nos sirvan
y los repasemos en directo la práctica pues trataremos de montar un porfolio y
ver estas ver estas cosas pero ya está claro que a nivel de a nivel de porfolio
un set de un sistema es un sistema es un sistema vale es un sistema de hecho
creo creo que enseñar sí yo creo que enseñar una matriz muestra
de segregado donde hay donde se ve algún sistema con mucha correlación eso es
justamente eso es el mismo sistema con otros parámetros porque porque si eso
si eso es robusto es mejor eso que poner el mismo sistema doblado porque es poca
diversificación es muy poca pero es alguna de acuerdo es más que es más que
poner el set doblado no pero claro eso te lo tiene que permitir el sistema
lo tiene que permitir el sistema porque tenga varias zonas de trabajo etcétera
pero en principio son sistemas independientes el cómo darle peso a cada
sistema esto ha habido varias preguntas ya he comentado que lo ya hable algo en la
teoría quizá no profundice mucho en ello pero se pueden tú puedes analizarlo
junto con el money management pues nosotros lo puedes hacer con porfolio
trader lo puedes hacer con maestro lo puedes hacer con msa que es un programa
sencillito y que os recomiendo bastante pero al final no os calentéis mucho de
verdad porque yo y esto también lo he leído de varios autores es realmente
complicado que en el futuro al menos yo hasta ahora no no he visto cómo no he
visto cómo mediante procesos de optimización que realmente en el futuro
acaben aportando mucho de acuerdo aportando mucho a al final poder puedes
porque igual que tú optimizas un sistema lo mismo tú tienes la cartera de
sistemas no tú has hecho todos tus sistemas los mezclas en cualquiera de
esos programas y tú optimizas ahí si quieres puedes optimizar los parámetros
puedes optimizar la gestión monetaria puedes optimizar muchas cosas pero no es
recomendable y el peso puedes decir pues mira voy a ver el peso porque al final a
mí eso me da un y puede haber cierto margen de este acuerdo pues meter
sort y no puedes meter sharp vale y tú dices voy a ver por sharp que mix de
sistemas me da mejor y me sale uno me sale que éste le pongo 10.000 que éste
le pongo a que éste pese un 20 que se pesa un 10 y se pesa un 30 no vale y yo
entiendo que sustentador entiendo que sustentador y no digo que que vayan al
100% igual vale a 100% igual pero yo recomiendo que trateis de acercaros
bastantes a lo que llamamos equal weight vale igual weight de eso sí ajustado
por volatilidad por volatilidad es decir al final pensar que el peso que le das
a un sistema depende de la volatilidad del activo lógicamente lógicamente pero
ya digo es que voy a decir cosas y al final no va a quedar del todo claro
porque es mejor verlo y ya lo lo veremos de acuerdo cuando lo tratemos discutiremos
sobre ello y ya veréis que además hablan opiniones distintas es interesante
es un tema muy interesante y que tiene mucho mucho debate vale pero sí que
debería que trátalo como sistemas independientes trátalo como sistemas
independientes porque en realidad lo son final es de cada uno tiene una curva no
por lo tanto cada cada curva es un sistema entonces al final cada mix
sistema activo pero es que es el mismo ya pero lo vas a operar con otra
combinación de parámetros por tanto la curva no es idéntica no pues es otro
sistema vale es otro sistema ahora también sentido común lo que decía
antes en el peso de acuerdo al final lógicamente si sólo tienes uno y tienes
cuatro el final hay que entender que estás mal diversificados es evidente es
decir al final aunque le pongas en 20 el peso un 20% cada uno en el fondo pues
estás de lo mismo es un momento que se me ha desconectado el auricular me había
desconectado el auricular
bien de medes harás poco diversificado no eso es evidente vale
papá sí bueno todo esto que me comentas va relacionado con la con la
con la supervisión si si esas zonas se determinan se determinan por el
histórico del sistema es evidente se determinan cuando empiezas por bactés
cuando ya opera un tiempo pues también ayuda el life de acuerdo ayuda el life
cuando ya ha operado pero evidentemente no no tienes otra referencia que el
bactés es decir que el bactés ahí sí que hay que nuevamente aplicar el sentido
común pero bueno lógicamente el histórico es una muy buena referencia y
ahí sí que montecarlo suele venir bien vale porque montecarlo da como un
escenario súper hostil de acuerdo la mayoría de sistemas es decir es él es
un poco el punto muy negro entonces al final te puede servir para este tipo de
cosas de referencia si no también una referencia en un periodo que no se
montecarlo por ejemplo es dos desviaciones sobre su media cosas así
vale dos desviaciones sobre su media estadísticamente suele suele estar
bien la media del ratio que tú mires pues dos desviaciones y el verde amarillo rojo
bueno rojo es que se ha salido de cuerpo y amarillo normalmente pues por ejemplo
es lo que nos ha pasado a nosotros ahora vale que bueno uno llegó a tocar llegó
a salirse vale pero pero el resto sabán en amarillo sabán en zona cercana hay
hay veces que hay veces como el que ni tan solo te saldrá que no te llega a
saltar el aviso pero tú ya lo ves sabes por lo que yo sí sí me seguís en los
directos de tuito que llamo la sensibilidad de los sistemas al final
cuando tú llevas un tiempo con un sistema pues tienes como sensibilidad a
él los que tengáis hijos no pues bueno pues ya sabes por dónde peca cada uno
ya sabes no hay cosas que ya las las las ves no sé si este es un buen ejemplo pero
bueno ya ya vente de él entonces también pasa eso también pasa eso pero si no
tienes sensibilidad pues tienes ahí tus métricas que saltan de acuerdo que
saltan
en el punto 6 preguntaba está mierda bueno todo va bastante relacionado con
con esos dos temas de hablar de un porfolio del excel
si se habla de la construcción del excel si si esto será bueno un poco vimos
vi una enseñe uno la teoría rápido pero sí sí que cuando hagamos el
porfolio lo veremos en excel sí lo veremos en excel porque porque me gusta
bastante enseñar el excel porque es donde se ven un poco la no no las tripas
pero se ve un poquito más los números de manera más sin tanto software y tanta
para hacer nadie se ve un poquito el origen de todo el origen de todo y se
entiende creo que se entiende bien así no en excel sí sí que lo haremos si
todo esto lo haremos lo mismo lo que comentas en el 7 que va lo mismo
relacionado con él con el excel y demás no la creación de un porfolio la
correlación entre sistemas se me dice retorno diario bueno hablé de diario
semanal mensual normalmente en mensual está bien pero sí que es verdad que
creo que esta tabla que comentas la enseñe en diario
10 años
esto eran datos de maestro daily si si están bien mensuales esto sí que lo
veremos si está bien mensual también de acuerdo es decir no no está mal no está
mal mensual no pensar que siempre diario de hecho también lo comenté a veces
puede tener alguna desventaja también en diario yo recomendaría en general este
tipo de estudios de muy largo plazo con muchas sistemas y demás trabajar los
datos en mensual no hace falta trabajarlos en diario vale es suficiente
referencia para hablar de esto de la mezcla de sistemas vale
qué más aquí a más rugat a meses 6 esto no sé qué es a meses 6 tal bueno
contexto en el paper pero este ya te lo dejo marcado
tengo este clip que hace que ya lo he visto vale a ver si te entiendo lo que
me preguntas aquí dices una estrategia al revés de 5 minutos de mercado
acciones americanas concluyendo un pobre retorno supresión básica y
mejorando más que lo tal de verla con el cuerpo el concepto stocks in play el
concepto juega con la métrica de volumen relativo de la marca de 5 minutos dividido
por la mayoría volumen de 14 días anteriores y si si si siendo esta usada
para renkear las acciones es el contexto venga he intentado usar un
escáner así escáner bueno la verdad que escáner nosotros últimamente lo
usamos poco
es posible que tengas razón o sea tres eso ya os lo vengo comentando yo confío
y es sólo confianza que no tarden en lanzar alguna nueva versión que la
convierta en más más capaz vale pero porque tiene el problema de ser de base
de 32 bits son algunas cosas como ésta como ésta pues se nota de todas maneras
sí que te diré nosotros tenemos este por ejemplo que escaneamos los reteféricos de
volumen automáticamente y demás que la única cosa que te puedo decir respecto
a esto entiendo que te refieres a escárner en órgano de skin vale es que
cuando tú tienes que usar un criterio que si si lengües es tarda mucho más si
puedes que navega porque hay muchos precio de tala y muchos aquí usar los
que tiene pre precreados él vale normalmente normalmente no vas a
conseguir mucha más velocidad eso sí te lo digo por lo demás no te puedo decir
también depende de lo que filtres cuántos enseñas vale al final hay
algunos que sólo son display display display aquí ves es elegir top 100 vale
cuando pones top 100 o mayor que un criterio lo que sea vale que hay que no
sé si estarás a lo mejor siendo muy muy exigente pero claro si te he entendido
bien tú me estás diciendo que estás filtrando 3.000 acciones en 5 minutos
no sé cuánto cargas de datos ahí pero claro la vela de 5 pues seguramente es
complicado complicado no se habría que mirarlo no sé si es viable o no si
viable es segura seguramente este tipo de cosas no es tres se son la mejor
herramienta hoy en día porque antes iba muy bien pero lo que digo es que hay
esto mira escáner por fue el maestro world for optimizer son herramientas que
siempre han estado muy bien pero están igual hace como 10 años que ahora igual
pero igual igual no en cambio nada entonces claro vosotros si cogéis ahora
un móvil de hace 10 años va a pedales literal literal va a pedales entonces
pues ya está ya se ha dicho todo entonces ya se ha dicho todo entonces
realmente son herramientas que están bien pero que cosa que no que saben que
están muy bien porque están muy bien realmente el concepto pues meter datos
fundamentales pero o sea necesita mejorar en procesamiento de datos
necesita mejorar en capacidad en recibimiento y maestro quizás la peor
porque si es si maestro igual lleva 15 igual entonces ese es un poco el problema
vale entonces si ya lo has probado lo único que te digo es eso que trates de
no usar y que tardes de usar las consultas suyas porque verás que lo
hace como en varias fases y verás que la que tarda es la vez de lenguas
la si bueno esto que comentas me sorprende que me lo preguntes porque lo
que lo he dicho varias veces lo de las sensaciones en la pobreza de
rendimiento de la herramienta de escáner terrestre no es en la herramienta de
escáneres en varias cosas de lo que te digo que por ejemplo a nivel gráfico a
nivel de la operativa para el que operan con el amátex está súper bien visual a
nivel de opciones me dicen yo no pero pero me dicen que está muy bien mejoró
muchísimo y y a nivel del easy language optimizar y demás también ahí
mejoraron bastante porque fue así que usa todos los procesadores
pero también también puede mejorar también puede mejorar pero sí sí o sea yo
yo tengo la sensación que trae si son no sé el motivo pero se está como
quedando atrás porque ya digo hace muchos años es así los años
haría falta una versión 11 supongo que ya sea de 64 bit y que mejore un poco
algunas de las herramientas que tiene si luego comentas también lo del tema del
roadmap y mi intención tal vez por deformación se esgarace en ingeniería
es tener un roadmap que encapsula el procedimiento tipo ser san cistern factor
y workshop no bueno la verdad si no si no tenéis la sensación que hay un roadmap
es que yo lo he explicado todo muy muy mal vale porque sí que lo hay sí que lo
hay lo que pasa que sí que es verdad que
que no le hemos puesto un nombre como hacen otros desarrolladores no le hemos
puesto un nombre pero pero sí que es así sí que es así y que sí que es verdad
que el hecho de hacer la teoría y la práctica en separado pues es verdad que
genera lo mejor una sensación extraña no de que en la práctica no no es ahora
volvemos a hacer la teoría volvemos a hacer la práctica no pensamos que era
mejor hacerla así a lo mejor nos hemos equivocado no sé ya digo al final ya nos
diréis vosotros para otras veces a ver si sí bueno otras veces es que las hay
porque no tengo claro que volvamos a hacer esto mismo tal como lo hemos hecho
realmente os lo digo porque es un esfuerzo y heavy muy heavy y entonces no
hemos puesto un nombre como tal vale pero pero sí que el procedimiento está y yo
creo que cuando hablamos del desarrollo que es el tema de largo casi todo el
curso es ese capítulo y os fijáis no y ahí yo hablaba de las fases tal es una
idea investigación no acordáis no todo esto y evaluación preliminar etcétera
etcétera entonces al final esas son un poco los pasos vale esos son un poco los
pasos lo que lo que pasa que bueno como al final es tiene matices sistema de
corto plazo de medio largo por sí que es verdad que yo en cada parte he ido
explicándolo todo y a lo mejor se ha perdido un poco el hilo de continuidad
que parecía que de pronto entrabas en un tema estabas ahí mucho tiempo luego
salías no pero en realidad sí que había un hilo sí que había un a una ruta una
ruta así que si si de cara a medida que vayamos
acercándonos al final seguiste en esa sensación pues ya lo
retrasaremos lo retrasaremos y dejaremos más claro todo todo esto no porque es
evidente que como ya os he comentado me interesa que todo el mundo quede que
entiendo que el 100% va a ser imposible porque no existe eso en la vida no el
100% en nada sólo en una cosa que nos falta recordar ahora y pero vamos a
tratar de que la mayor gente posible quede muy muy contenta con el curso
entonces al final pues bueno a medida que nos acercamos al final pues si hay
algo así oye que hay que repasar un tema pues si vemos que es algo general no
pues se puede hacer una encuesta y se decide hacer algún otro repaso de algún
tema o lo que sea que ya digo que que una de las principales ventajas como
comentando es la capacidad que tenéis de influir en el curso no todavía los que
lo estáis haciendo en directo vale bueno y hasta luego añadí ahí para el
tema de maestro y demás y ahora mientras escribíamos raúl estaba
estaba escribiendo ahora estaba escribiendo y decía que ha estado
haciendo unas pruebas o optimizar el don chian y ha tenido problemas bueno el
maestro no bien bienvenido bienvenido al club tanto evitando estrategias en un
chat en un solo activo con porfile maestro a entonces ya no tanto eso ya
si bueno esto esto no es un problema para un esto es que no tiene sentido hacer la
genética esto no es un problema este aviso que te sale quiere decir que tú
has el tú has querido hacer genética una optimización que haciendo la
exhaustiva tienen menos generaciones entonces te dice no tiene sentido vale
no tiene sentido hacer la genética porque el número de el número que has
elegido genético es mayor que la exhaustivo así que te dice te la
cambio a exhaustiva esto no es un fallo esto simplemente es que te la cambia
exhaustiva y la hace vale y es correcto tiene que ser así cuando tienes pocas
es la exhaustiva aquí en el maestro el maestro optimizar es
de verdad bueno pero pero es ahí sí que no usa 60 no usa todos los
procesadores sólo te va a usar un núcleo entonces lentísimo maestro
optimizando pero lo mismo te dice lo mismo te dice que que el número de
combinaciones es muy pequeña para hacer genética te dice que sólo tienes 1050
que es menos de 5000 por lo tanto pues que no la hagas que la hagas exhaustiva
lo mismo te dice lo mismo esto esto en sí no es un fallo esto esto es que te
está avisando que la hagas exhaustiva aún estás en el directo si no ya lo verás
ya lo verás luego vale si si te pasa exhaustiva no la estás haciendo
incorrecto que es que la tienes que hacer exhaustiva o sea cuando cuando el
número de combinaciones es menor haciendo exhaustiva que genética no tiene
sentido hacer la genética no tiene sentido es decir tú pensas que tenés
eso te deja guardar hasta 8.000 que nosotros sólo lo guardamos para hacer
el mapa cuando queremos hacer mapa hacemos mapa
entonces si no no guardas tantas entonces fíjate si tienes menos que 8.000 es que
las puedes guardar todas entiendes o sea tú la en el performance en el informe de
las puedes sacar las 8.000 entonces sacas las 8.000 las llevas a excel y ahí ya las
trabajas tienes no no tiene no tiene no tiene sentido si tú quieres hacer
genético por el por la por lo que hemos hablado que quizá por ahí la cosa de
que el genético te permite esa búsqueda que a mí por eso me gusta más el
genético que otros ratios que otros algoritmos jambre y esos nombres que
alguna vez que no me acuerdo pero genético para mí es que es muy bueno
para nuestro tipo de para nuestro problema no para encontrar soluciones a
nuestro problema yo creo que el genético es muy bueno es muy bueno
entonces si quieres eso pues tienes que abrir más tienes que abrir más no te
queda otro tienes que o grabar más el incremento tienes que hacer que el que
la población sea más grande para que todo este diga vale ya la puedes hacer
genética eso es vale no sé si me había dicho aquí si me había hecho pilar aquí
que había alguna pregunta y si me estás oyendo tratar de ponerlas mejor aquí
vale ya sé que aquí también ponen preguntas del curso pero si vais a si
veis aquí arriba creo que lo ponía lo ponía poner las en el hilo tal van
preguntas que hagas en el curso pues también puedes preguntar vosotros las
ponas en el hilo tal por favor que era el otro pero bueno que no pasa nada es por
un tema de orden si esto es por una limitación de capital tienes que
operar en futuros micro tú puedes hacer perfectamente es normal que hagas
primero una pequeña podemos decir evaluación preliminar de la base de
datos y compares poniendo el código en uno y otro vale pero puedes usar
normalmente puedes usar el grande para hacer tus análisis sin ningún tipo de
problema vale normalmente si normalmente no tiene mayor problema igual
que nosotros por ejemplo gestión monetaria a veces la dimensionamos a
mucho más de lo que vamos a operar porque interesa interesa ver cómo cómo
se mueve no porque al final en el futuro es tan grande con lo que han subido que
el nominado es tan gigantesco que tienes que poner ahora por ejemplo en el
rebe éste estábamos poniendo no sé si 10 millones porque claro el tax es que es
gigantesco entonces no es muy grande entonces sí puedes hacerlo pero tú
analízalo normalmente no te va a salir igual no te va a ser igual ya porque
puede haber algún pequeño trate de diferencia puede haber pero sobre todo
porque son más caros realidad si tú miras el valor de el valor de tanto por
deslizamiento como por el valor de las garantías que te retienen y el valor
sobre todo del tic el valor mínimo el mínimo movimiento que tiene el futuro
respecto al nominal suele ser un poco mayor no en todos pero muchos es un
poco mayor entonces al final es un poquito menos eficiente pero bueno es
lo que hay es lo que hay y es mucho más eficiente poder operar varios que solo
uno tienes con lo cual lo que pierdes por un lado lo puedes ganar por otro
porque es mejor que sólo puedas operar yo que sé el lsp mini y si a mejor vas a
micros pues puedes operar el sp el oro el euro dólar sabes pues mejor mucho
mejor es mucho mejor así que si si ningún problema en eso y y normalmente
puedes usarse ningún tipo de problema el el que tenga más volumen me acuerdo
que es un poco el que el que el mercado considere como como el que manda no ese
normalmente suele ser el más antiguo el más antiguo a ver que había alguna
cosita por aquí tengo que contestar algo de aquí arriba alberto de que vaya a
relacionado con este tema lo dejamos para después está la aurelia añadía
no que necesita pues concreciones ya si si si si no no si lo entiendo lo que
pasa que la la el problema es que las sabes que pasa esto esto es como la
lo comentaba el otro día no yo creo que que que hacer un curso con alguien que
está operando actualmente que se dedica a esto tiene muchas ventajas pero también
alguna es ventaja de acuerdo una que puede parecer pero que yo creo que no
lo es pero puede parecer es que la práctica sabes es como a veces no
tienes aquella sensación con los que hayáis estudiado en la universidad o es
igual data lo mismo que hayas estudiado que tú te pones a trabajar en el tema y
no tienes ni puñetera idea y has estado siete años en la universidad
estoy seguro que alguno alguno ha tenido esta sensación no ha hecho una
ingeniería mencias no y tu primer trabajo después de la universidad no
tuviste la sensación que estabas que no que no que no tenía nada que ver no
pero ya me entiendes no que realmente hostia lo que te habían enseñado está
muy lejos de la práctica no está muy lejos de la práctica del trabajo del
día a día que hacías no yo yo a mí me ha pasado la pasada mi hija no sé de mis
amigos yo sé yo tengo la sensación de que es algo muy común a lo mejor a
mejores no no es no todo el mundo pensáis igual no pues es un poco esto
vale lo que pasa ahora ahora estamos haciendo al revés estamos haciendo
alguien que hace práctica no que hace teoría y tienes entonces yo no soy como
un catedrático que seguramente te lo explicaría todo de una manera mucho más
estructurada tal luego no serviría para nada no serviría para nada pero sería
súper guay no y acabaría ser el curso como mola esto sale que qué bien y tal
pero no usarías nada de lo que te explicas pues es un poco el caso justo
contrario caso justo contrario que venimos de la práctica al final pues
vamos como el día a día lo que te digo para que un problema con apolo eso se
pues lo podíamos explicar sabes o sea es un poco el caso contrario entonces
bueno a mejor no hay esa estructura tan tan académica no no tenemos esa
estructura tan tan académica de tan acostumbrados a dar siempre la clase la
clase pero bueno pues puede a mejor en algunas cosas en una desventaja pero yo
creo que en general pues tiene tiene una tiene más ventajas que desventajas pero
como todo en la vida pues hay cosas buenas y cosas malas bueno vamos a si si
no no si si lo si lo si lo lo comparto y trato trato de hacerlo y en la en la
teoría al dar pautas concretas lo intentaba hacer pero sí que es verdad
que el tema es que al final nuestro el tema del teclado agrémico es una
disciplina que en el fondo en el fondo si las si tú lo mirarás materia materia
bueno que también pasa con una ingeniería si me entiendes tocas muchas
cosas distintas y seguro que la ingeniería no sé en tu caso de qué es
pero no debe tener nada que ver me imagino porque no no es mi caso no
construir un puente con construir un campo de fútbol o construir un edificio
un chalet o construir no sé una mina o construir un rascacielos de 74 pisos
me imagino porque a lo mejor resulta que estoy igual y me estoy tirando un triple
aquí espectacular entonces pues bueno aquí con lo con los temas pasa pasa
pasa bastante eso que es verdad que sí que al final hay cosas en común pero
pero tiene bastantes diferencias una cosa de la otra pero bueno yo creo que al
final con la viéndolo todo acabarás teniendo más más claro de todo el de
todo el proceso porque porque bueno en cuando cuando hagamos en dos tres
sistemas de esta manera tenía intención de devolver un poco al tema busquedad y
de repasar un poco este guión y más ahora que veo que hay menos dos tres
personas que me da la sensación que os que decís que falta esa estructura pues
lo repasaremos desde el origen siempre siempre hemos pensado hacerlo siempre
lo que pasa que bueno pensamos que era mejor empezar así pero pensamos que era
mejor empezar viendo un poco sistemas de gráfico y tal no y explicando ideas ya
partiendo de ideas que habían salido en el curso porque tanto el concepto don
chan como el concepto rb breakout pues había salido en el curso no bueno es
revés directamente el sistema hecho no pero si he explicado como categoría y
además si no recuerdo mal creo que lo dije que le haríamos uno en revés y por
cierto hablando de rb vamos con ello vamos con ello vamos con ello que es lo
que nos ocupa ver alguna cosa más por aquí esto es de el bueno de álvaro a
ver y ahora espérate que no sé si me puedo no me puedo abrir el momento tengo
que dejar tengo que dejar de compartir un momento la pantalla o a ver una cosa
has guardado en el dedicado eso alberto para que lo pueda abrir porque ahora no
puedo abrir es dedicado porque se va a ver la ip no no que esos unos piratas
esos unos piratas todos sobre sobre aurel y este el árbol y te revienta el
servidor seguro y raúl tremendo pues juan manuel y te cuento sus ponen ahí los
tres voy a ser en diario y te cuento que este no nos revienta ante todo están ahí todo si si
si escucho alto y claro alberto a coño lo cerrado y jaimito lo acabo de cerrar no me
da cuenta si lo acabo de cerrar no me da cuenta ya no no lo voy abriendo ya está
sí sí ya lo sé ya pero bueno pues está desde el 2000 2002 si en multichar no no
en multichar se para luego lo tengo montado de abrir multichar bueno vamos a
ver empezamos lo voy abriendo porque como son muchos datos me va a tardar además al
final lo hemos hecho con dos datas porque no veíamos claro del todo cómo
hacerlo con un data y al final lo hemos montado con dos esa es la carpeta del
curso no entiendo alberto óptico en cómics o al abro hombre dime uno con
cómics nada con cómics y está los en cómics es mentira ya ya lo sé ya lo sé
que muchos papers y sí porque el paper ese era ese cómics era muy baja sí bueno
a ver de momento mira voy a subiros aquí hoy tengo bastante material que
daros de hecho tengo tanto material que no os lo voy a poder poner a bueno pero
lo puede ir borrando creo sí sí mira vamos a ir haciendo para ser claro todo
el mundo no lo va a poder ver todo el rato de momento tengo el ahí os dejo ya
el paper de del rb vale bueno el paper el el pdf ya os lo he puesto ahí que
recoge un poco la explicación del rb que hemos dejado este que hemos hecho
que vamos a ver hoy que al final lógicamente es parecido a la anterior
parecido también a lo que puso senen que lo habréis visto ahí en el disco
interesante de un concurso que hizo mi buen amigo roberto que de un concurso que
hizo y puso pues una pequeña plantilla que se lo es básico al final el rb no
tiene mucha bueno sí que tiene todo tiene al final todo tiene porque al
final puedes filtrar no tiene no tiene me refiero en el cuerpo principal luego
en el filtro ahí puedes filtrar por lo que te dé la gana pero en el cuerpo
principal está bastante bastante cerrada la idea de acuerdo porque un
open range breakout pues es eso puedes variar las horas tal pero es eso pero sí
que evidentemente en cuanto a filtros demás pues se puede vale se puede este
de hecho os lo os lo os lo hemos explicado aquí en el en el pdf vale
pero lo vamos a ir viendo en el gráfico el pdf os lo pongo ahí porque así lo
podéis vosotros también abrir y ir ir viendo vale ir viendo cuantos tres
tenemos aquí 1800 straight nada mal tenemos c6 bastante bajos
los c6 bastante bajos si muy muy bajo hay un par de cosas que no que no hemos
implementado porque todavía no lo hemos hecho y para el siguiente ya metamos que
es lo que hablábamos antes no hay esto de volatilidad aquí por el final los
cps y estos que hemos hecho son por porcentaje no son por ajustados por atr
y es bastante recomendable hacerlo bueno volviendo al documento que si lo tenéis
ahí yo lo tengo aquí en otra pantalla para poder compaginar el el sistema que
veáis el sistema y yo voy hablando del paper no del documento vale simplemente
veis ahí los parámetros que hemos incorporado os hablé no os hablé de las
las cosas típicas que hay hay alguna más que se puede hacer vale pero las
cosas típicas una la ventana la ventana temporal en el que vimos del libro de
caos man que es uno de los más clásicos que es basado en el rango de la primera
hora basado en el rango de la primera hora a partir de ahí tú puedes montarlo
de variando poniendo una hora de inicio de acuerdo poniendo una hora de inicio y
un número de barras que en esa hora evalúe vale y eso es lo que hemos hecho
aquí tú pones una hora pones las 10 y entonces a partir de ahí puedes
trabajarlo como quieras acordaros os hablaba del dax por ejemplo de decir
hombre el dax yo aquí lo he cargado mira esto alberto lo ha trabajado en el lo
ha trabajado en el lsp en horarios regular y en 10 minutos en horarios
regular y 10 minutos y es pobrísimo el sistema es realmente pobrísimo no digo
tal como está puesto así es pobrísimo es realmente súper pobre tiene algún
filtro activo alberto y es 30 530 barras con 8 barras con high con low sin filtro
entrada tres días de filtro de tendencia y curioso bueno y le metemos 15
dólares de penalización de 15 dólares le metemos 15 dólares cuando tiene una
verad straight de 600 no sé bueno si si supe mucho pero es que es lo que hay si
si el problema de los interadías siempre siempre es eso pero tiene tiene
capacidad de mejora esto se puede conseguir unos revés con una curva
bastante más bastante más estable bastante más estable es verdad que hay
autores un cambio que puede ser que mejore no lo he probado pero lo voy a
probar ahora mismo aquí tengo también puesto el que paso
cenen espérate espérate porque me voy a por los huesos vamos a repasar vamos a
repasar el sistema vale vamos a repasar este va para que lo entendáis de acuerdo
está explicado pero mejor que lo que lo tendáis ese es el que el que digo que
está en el discord vale que estará el disco el que lo pasó cenen lo pasó
cenen mira que es lo que os decía vale digo aquí por ejemplo esto el que pasó
robert no iba con máximo sino con el mayor entre el open y el close esto es
una manera de tratar de adelantar la entrada a tratar de adelantar la entrada
es decir tiene tiene suficiente capacidad predictiva ver los máximos
entre el open y el close si la respuesta es sí normalmente vas a entrar antes que
con el highest es más seguro pero es verdad que es más lento entonces cuando
estamos hablando de lsp que no estamos hablando del activo más tendencia del
mundo a nivel interdiario pues avanzarse es nosotros esto solemos hacerlo con el
típico el price solemos hacerlo con el típico el price en vez de usar esto pero
busca un poco lo mismo entonces ahora luego lo probaremos luego lo probaremos
bien ese es el código vale ese es el código lo tenéis también en el pdf lo
tenéis en el pdf el código vale y creo que el pdf estos los hago abiertos es
decir que tú aquí puedes copiar y pegar puedes copiar y pegarse ningún tipo de
problema coges aquí todo y le pegas el código y fuera te lo pongo si les
ya lo tienes más fácil que pasando el código porque es lo que hemos visto ahí
con senen en el disco nos va a bloquear nos va a poner problemas entonces pues
casi es mejor pasar el pdf y vosotros lo copiar y pegar haces nueva estrategia lo
pegas y está en sí tiene tiene lo que os decía una ventana horaria vale con la
que controlamos la hora de inicio y unas barras es decir yo cuento seis barras en
esa hora calcula el rango previo que yo le diga si yo vengo aquí si yo vengo
aquí le digo pues esto es el s p en horario regular que abre 830 en velas de
10 minutos vale pues si le digo a las 10 pues tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 9 a las 10
tengo nueve quiero hacer así pues algo así si no pues puedo definir el rango
como quiera lógicamente puedo hacerlo también por optimización pero es verdad
que ahí tendríamos que hacer algún algún ajuste porque optimizar las
parámetros de velas al no estar en en algebraico es un poco más complicado es
un poco más complicado se puede pero hay que hacer una conversión en el código
que no hemos hecho pero sé que sé que se podría aquí creo que tenemos 10 30 a
10 30 exactamente los 10 30 a partir de las 10 30 puede puede operar ahí define
el rango de acuerdo y ahí puede operar lo hemos hecho totalmente flexible en el
sentido que podéis hasta definir el precio el precio que usa para para
calcular el precio la banda alta la banda baja lo que decía ahora tú aquí
puedes poner típica el price puedes poner típica el price o puedes poner o
sea tú en los inputs de 3d eso puedes poner esto que veis aquí esto lo puedes
poner esto mismo si quieres cualquier fórmula que como resultado de un precio
lo puedes poner es decir tú puedes venir aquí y poner eso pues hacer eso
si quieres también típica el price cualquier palabra reservada o función
que como resultado de un número que es un precio al final bueno que de un
número él lo va a usar un número que no que en el código no dé un error que
cualquier cosa que de un número pues no va a dar error pues al final es está
entonces ya he puesto algunos comentarios es este es el final rango de entrada y
también hemos puesto una hora de fin por lo que os decía en el dax no decir bueno
pues yo también quiero explorar el controlar el rango de entrada pero
también el de salida vale y en el dax es especialmente útil yo os lo
comentaba además de una cosa explorar muy interesante en el dax aquí ahora
mismo ese no lo hemos trabajado demasiado fatal pero a lo tengo cargado creo que
con sesión regular exactamente pero puedes explorar el dax puedes probar por
ejemplo cargarlo desde las 8 cargarlo desde antes y tú a lo mejor por esto
operativa a las 10 y le puedes que calcule de 30 barras antes de decir que
el rango use todo el previo entiendes es un ejercicio que se anima a probar
el código es el mismo pero tú puedes cargar la sesión que quieras y le metes regular a
bueno no está cargado con regular ahora se ha cargado regular pues el chavo que
estaba cargado con con la si si está cargado con regular vamos a explorar brevemente vamos
a explorar brevemente pero claro imagínate las barras que tenemos para que empiece a operar
vamos a poner hasta las 8 que define al rango hasta las 8 porque normalmente esos sistemas la
verdad que les gusta anticiparse a poner 9 como cada hora son 10 no 20 40 50 60 si no son 6
coño 10 6 6 cada hora 12 son dos horas 2 pues mira en las dos horas previas de 7 a 9 que
define al rango que estás en filtros de momento es para evaluarlo aquí es lo que os decía por
ir rebasando conceptos de acuerdo tú puedes definir la idea así cuando yo os digo incluso
aún podíamos haberle metido algún filtro más no quiere decir que los uses todos faltaría el
devolumen por ejemplo vale no quiere decir que los estos pero si los puedes investigar pero hacerlo
por separado lo que os decía es decir tú ahora pruebas el sistema buscas tu entrada lo trabajas
trabajas la entrada de distintas pruebas haces alguna optimización de la entrada sólo la entrada
y vas haciendo así input por input claro es que maravilla una maravilla es un misil le damos la
vuelta y ya lo tenemos ya lo tenemos se va a tomar viento la forma espera pero la salida
lo tengo cargado todo pero le voy a poner salida también a las ocho 40 a las ocho y media
para que pierda un poco más un poco más un poquito más poquito peor poquito peor
se dura más mejor un poco pero muy poco entonces esto es la idea lo bueno que es lo que os digo lo
bueno es que los sistemas intradía tienes muchísimo margen de maniobra y aquí hay
cargado mucho histórico expresamente todo el que me deja tener eso creo que es 2002
vale lo que es 2002 el dado es para el filtro de tendencia porque le puedes permitir que vaya
pero no se ha activado ahora está en bruto a comprar a una hora y vender a vender a la otra y
esta no tiene nada no puede ni salir por otro método es decir que realmente que ahora sí tendría
bastante mérito en tantos años porque claro no tiene manera de salirse se se equivoca acuerdo
no tiene manera de salirse se equivoca se lo traga nada más que lo hubieras metido un stop aquí
pues no sé esto mismo le metes un stop de yo que sé pero 5% por ejemplo que ahora
solo hemos implementado el trailing aquí creo si solo hemos solo hemos implementado el trailing
pero 5% lo normal es que tenga alguna alguna mejora que 0 5% es bastante pero 5% es bastante
ahora repaso los los importar la mejora de nada la mejora de nada no sé si ha hecho 4500
que es siendo trailing otra cosa que os sugeriría aquí es explorar el stop fijo
aún va peor el stop fijo si te ve y fijo vale que de hecho lo tenía montado y lo sacado al final
pero bueno ya digo al final no deja de ser un ejemplo para explicaros conceptualmente la
idea vale de todas maneras de este sistema ya os comenté que este sí que tengo la firme intención
de entregaros uno que se ha acabado pero me gusta que intentéis vosotros trabajarlo la
práctica no sólo consiste eso sí que era la teoría donde yo soltaba el rollo vale aquí aquí
la idea es que vosotros lo lo tratáis de trabajar bien en tres eso no en otra plataforma igual por
eso os paso el código vale por eso os paso el código y os paso el suyo código delante está
explicado antes el código está explicado el código de cómo funciona eso es el suyo código
vale yo os lo dije os pasaríamos el suyo código entonces os paso lo que hay a partir de ahí yo
también durante la clase comentó comentó distintas distintas cosas os explico lo que
hace esta versión y os explico también os sugiero otras cosas a probar vale y es lo que vamos a ver
ahora bien siguiendo con la explicación de lo que de lo que hace el sistema la entrada es tan
sencilla como esa pero tiene cuatro filtros de acuerdo cuatro filtros que se pueden activar o
no activar nosotros casi siempre los filtros los diseñamos así de acuerdo es decir que el código
ya permita activarlos o no vale un truco muy sencillo ya lo visteis en el otro sistema era
esto que con un valor de cero es simplemente con un simple condición de if filtro tendencia es
mayor que cero vale entonces actúa si es que no pues no actúa entonces ya le pasas que es que la
condición quede en true para que si no interfiera el filtro de acuerdo entonces es un pequeño truco
que puede servir para para para evaluar un filtro para evaluar un filtro vale entonces
cuáles son los cuatro filtros bueno filtro de entrada es decir un tanto por ciento de acuerdo
sobre el canal simplemente hemos añadido esa posibilidad la verdad que lo normal es que se
quede en cero yo os lo digo también pero ahí está ahí está vale para si queréis darle un
rango está en porcentaje vale un rango al precio vale luego hay un filtro de tendencia de acuerdo
un filtro de tendencia que simplemente calcula la tendencia en el gráfico diario vale para
permitirle ir solo largo solo corto dependiendo de la tendencia es decir dependiendo de si el
cierre del data 2 vale es mayor que la media de n cierres del dato 2 vale en el gráfico se ve muy
claro es esta media móvil de aquí abajo bueno es decir si tú es simplemente esa colección se
puede implementar de otra manera y hay distintas distintas opciones vale en el ejemplo que pasó
ser el de roberto creo que lo que tiene es un momento vale es un cierre menor que cierre
anterior que eso es un momento vale eso es exactamente lo que hace el indicador momento
exactamente es comparar el cierre de un día con el cierre de el cierre de una barra con el cierre
de n barras momentum de 14 pues es el cierre de hoy con el cierre de hoy o de la barra actual en
el time frame que sea con el cierre de 14 vale entonces puede estar bien hacer de momento que
es un poco no es lo mismo pero es un concepto totalmente análogo lo puedes hacer con una
nosotros lo hemos implementado con la media entonces su otra vez voy a cerrar ya esto
porque se va a abrir todo el rato el correo entonces simplemente es eso tú le dices si
activas el filtro para que en este día por ejemplo vale por ejemplo en este día para que pueda
comprar el día anterior tiene que haber cerrado por encima de la media vamos a suponer que le
activo no sé cuánto tiene activo ahora tiene activo en tres para que sea poco más visual se
lo voy a poner en 10 vale igual lo pongo en 10 no no ya lo sé que tardar es que tenemos muchos
años tenemos un montón de años metidos masiados voy a cerrarlo un poco más que nada porque además
son muchos años para para evaluar uno rb en 10 minutos son demasiados años no hace falta meter
23 años es demasiado voy a dejar en 10 sabes 10 años y está más que nada porque va a ir más
rápido no cada vez que haga un cambio voy a estar aquí 15 minutos esto le comentas un joe
manuel lo que dice que veo que veo que tiene una pregunta y pero las marcaba ya como esa
contestaba la última pues de que no pues se me da cuenta pero yo lo he leído si donde estamos
operando esa última no lo he leído de verdad 7 26 hace cinco minutos no no lo he leído en serio
que no se han leído bueno para ir largo en esta acuerdo el día anterior esta esta vela tiene que
estar por encima de la media eso es lo que hace ese filtro de tal forma que aquí en esta solo
puede ir corto no puede ir largo al día siguiente por eso al final no compra se puede activar no se
puede activar se puede usar una media se puede usar otra vale es decir eso es ese ese concepto
de decir yo voy a favor o en contra como ves el meterle la media de 10 ha ido mucho peor como veis
meterle la media 10 ha ido mucho peor pero ese es el ese es el filtro de tendencia probarlo también
el momento es decir al final esto como os digo es es probar y lo bueno en los interiores que se
puede probar con cierta tranquilidad pero a menos lo que os decía en los interiores más difícil
encontrar señal creo que sí es más difícil encontrar señal la señal es más sucia y también
es más fácil hacerse tampas al solitario entonces si uno al final es muy habitual porque no pongo
comisiones al final me entiende si yo no pongo comisiones pues mejoro mucho resultado
pero mucho resultado eso es así tienes otro hecho sin comisiones un poco sigo repasando
aquí en el paper porque va a tardar va a tardar un poco vale lo que lo que os decía vale el
otro filtro el otro filtro que tenemos después del filtro de tendencia que simplemente compara
el cierre del día anterior del data 2 con la media tiene barras del data 2 vale tenemos
el filtro de narro red acordaros que os expliqué y os comenté que una de las pautas que funciona
mejor en general los mercados y por supuesto rumbo la tibia que aún no va a ser de otra manera es
el concepto de expansión contracción hay varias maneras de mirar esto esta es una esta es una
hemos querido implementar esta porque os hablé porque os enseñé los vimos los artículos de
krabbel es uno de los autores que más reconocidos en el tema por por los joys revés y como vi que
estaba en esto con commodities pues ya os adelanto que los t los tenemos vale los tenemos
los hemos traducido y demás nos hemos puesto un poco así bonitos vale y ahora los voy a ir
subiendo ahí vale como son 8 como son 8 de momento voy a subir voy a dejar ahí 4 bueno
espérate que si no si no me cuando acabe esto es los otros subos cuando acabes pero pero bueno
al final un filtro de narro red que es simplemente que el rango el rango de la sesión se va
estrechando de acuerdo el rango de la sesión el rango viene definido por la diferencia entre
el máximo y el mínimo ya tenemos una función que se llama range pero si lo hubieras hecho
restando el high del low es lo mismo es lo mismo el rango del data 2 que sea menor que la media de
los rangos de las n barras anteriores este es un filtro esto que te está diciendo bueno que el
mercado se está contrariendo se está contrariendo también es un filtro que se puede activar en el
sistema este es el que has puesto sin comisiones no bueno este lo ha puesto sin comisiones alberto
y pues seguramente ha encontrado mejores mejores resultados no habrás encontrado mejores mejores
resultados bueno y sales del 21 no 1 19 sigue estando justito pero pues ya ya sea mejor tampoco
mejor no tampoco mejor es lo que decíamos de las trampas al solitario gente que le gusta hacerlo
pero porque si ya si ya te quito estos primeros 1000 ya ni te cuento al final este sin comisiones
y comisiones entonces ya de una curva más atractiva pero esa realidad no es verdad que
pues es fácil como os decía a ver si aquí tenemos a uno que equilibre mejor este bastante
mejor y mira este bastante mejor más tendencial además que se lo le no le he quitado histórico
el pdp es el que tengo aquí cuáles son como dices bueno este es el filtro de narro red
clave explicaba varios y hay varios autores que hay varias maneras de mirar lo otro simplemente
la volatilidad es decir que la volatilidad esté bajando también es una manera sencilla de evaluar
de evaluar eso que la volatilidad esté bajando que la volatilidad actual sea más baja que la
volatilidad media de enedías un poquito puede ser otra otra pauta pero en definitiva por ahí van
los tiros en los los o es revés por ahí van los los tiros de mirar este tipo este tipo de pautas
una es volatilidad o volumen volatilidad volumen vale otro relacionado con ello contracción
expansión bien por una narro red bien por un insight bar también por un insight bar es decir
que la vela del día anterior por ejemplo tiene su máximo sea menor al máximo anterior y su mínimo
sea mayor que se entiende eso no esperar que como tengo como tengo que se la puedo cerrar
ese todavía creo que va a ir mejor la curva ya verás maravilla alberto para maravilla no
pero bueno le quitamos le quitamos esta parte todavía está más trampa sólo lo que dije ya
lo he hecho muchas veces esto en el curso no esperéis porque me niego absolutamente a hacer
un curso donde sólo enseñe cosas maravillosas porque este mismo verá te lo cargo desde 2008 y
tienes aquí una maravilla los contentos joder qué bien qué fenómeno no tiene comisiones está
optimizado a saco para hacerse una idea del sistema para hacerse una idea del sistema pero
pero sin más es y más entonces lo que lo que os decía que es una que es un insight bar para
los que no lo tengáis del todo claro una insight bar vale tienes una vela desde que ha abierto
aquí por ejemplo y ha cerrado aquí vale y la del día siguiente es esta vale esta vela tenía
que ser azul el color a mí a un color más adecuado ser bueno se ve no pero por si acaso
no se ve lo pongo da igual si cierra abajo arriba en general términos generales igual pues esta
vela esta vela es una insight bar y es un signo claramente de contracción es una manera de
identificar una una contracción una contracción entonces pues lo mismo como un doji o una vela
cercana a un quasi doji cosas así o sea este tipo de filtros se utilizan bastante en los
sistemas de breakout porque se considera que antes que una expansión bien anticipada por
una contracción entonces cualquier indicador que mire eso como os digo pues lo mismo volatilidad
decreciente que tú veas una tr que va bajando no que la volatilidad bajando vale pues un mercado
así normal normalmente aumenta pero normalmente no lo que haces aumentar las probabilidades de
el siguiente porque porque cuando haya una rotura de rango también incluso también hay algunos
volatilidad de breakouts que podemos llamar open o no que no solo utilizan espero que borro esto
que no solo utilizan el open range acuerdo que basan el range del día anterior así que
pueden mover la ventana vale pueden mover la ventana pueden mover la ventana es decir yo puedo
usar puedo usar este rango de hecho los pivot points los pivot points que los conocéis basan
un poco en eso porque al final su cálculo depende del cierre anterior el máximo el mínimo anterior
con eso calcula los pivos del día entonces al final es una es una referencia y hay muchas
estrategias que utilizan en bien sea para para para volatilidad de breakouts o como para
mid reversion porque ya os lo comenté este semana lo puedes explorar como mid reversion
aquí el rango justo compre se va para abajo ahí tú hubieras vendido realmente es lo mismo es decir
que cuando haya un canal y vuelva es muy típico en el de volinger cuando lo veamos lo veamos lo
lo veis que es justamente esto es sale del rango pero vuelve y ahí vendes es ese ejemplo clarísimo
aquí sería un corto clarísimo que final es una un fallo y buscarlo puedes buscar eso también con
la estrategia porque buscas la rotura buscas el fallo decir cuando sale de un rango y vuelve
él cierra por otra vez por debajo ahí entras porque nuevamente provoca movimientos fuertes
los fallos provoca movimientos fuertes ya os lo comenté que la mayoría de sistemas se pueden
explorar en ambos varios lados en varios lados bien entonces siguiendo con las con la explicación
del de la estrategia siguiendo con la explicación de la de los filtros que que hay este simplemente
el rango vale que que hace propuesto la práctica bueno pues aquí lo lo tenemos lo tenemos puesto
aquí con las las comisiones bueno lo he ido tocando los parámetros ya no sé cuáles cuáles tengo
puestos pero por ejemplo si lo dejamos desactivado o no nada nada alberto no me he dejado el café
aquí a mitad de la es ahora he desactivado el filtro es operado bastante más el filtro pues sí
que estaba estaba aportando de acuerdo estaba aportando algo normal es que aporten algo aquí
es importante eso que os digo este es el clásico sistema por eso me gustaba mucho como ejemplo y
lo para el día no sé si para el día siguiente voy a poder pero vamos a intentarlo vamos a
intentarlo vamos a intentar en este hacer el procedimiento bien hecho completo es decir lo
que lo que lo que explicaba ahora un poco aurel y de los pasos no porque ese es el clásico donde
tú empiezas primero evaluando la señal primaria lo que se explicaba cuando hablamos de las de las
entradas de acuerdo de las entradas de acuerdo por es unas salidas fijas y vas evaluando la entrada
vale primero y luego ya vas a los filtros es un ejemplo que se ve muy bien la idea que hay
cuáles son las variables principales y las dependientes de acuerdo cuáles son las principales
sobre pues lógicamente el horario y el rango y si me apuras el campo que usas en la barra de acuerdo
para saltar que esas solos dejar la entrada entonces puedes dejar la salida fija podías y
recomiendo hacerlo y de hecho lo para nosotros hacer ese proceso lo vamos a hacer también meter
tp y esto fijo para poder usar como decimos en el de acción el trailing o o no usar el trailing o
usar esto ptp porque para evaluarlo viene bien porque ahí puedes ir a buscar riesgo igual o 2
a 1 cosas así pues puedes evaluarlo mejor y si no salida fin de día salida fin de día o salida
una hora bastante avanzada y hasta ahí evaluas la entrada haces una optimización puedes hacer
un mapa y ver un poquito en qué horarios jugar cómo se mueve y a partir de ahí es coger la
ventana de entrada independientemente de los filtros luego ya pasamos a trabajar los filtros
fase por fase aquí el filtro el filtro supongo que no lo hemos explorado en rangos muy elevados
porque claro en lo pones cortos muy sensible pero tú pues yo que sé imagínate unos 10 días que es
mucho 10 días en 10 días si nada es igual en 10 días pues ha quedado más o menos más o menos
igual aquí en 5 tiene una cierta mejora pero había que estudiarla había que hacer un mapa
habría que ver muchas muchas muchas pases se me había que trabajarlo bastante por fases vale
pero este es el filtro de rango que os decía de acuerdo filtro de narrow range que es bastante
utilizado aunque insisto que puede usar volatilidad volumen insight bar dos y distintos
componentes de este de este estilo vale qué más número de trades que puede hacer por día siempre
se suele en un intervía controlar y hasta a nivel de entrada es lo que tenemos aquí en la salida
simplemente hemos implementado un trailing y salir a una hora lo que os decía salir a una hora fija
cuando la hora sea mayor que x pues sale la apertura de la siguiente vela y se acabó si no
lo ha sacado el trailing antes de acuerdo y bueno tenemos esta es una seguridad los intervía que
dices por si haya un fallo que no se acaba el horario antes o lo que sea al menos garantiza
que al final pues el sistema se sale en el backtest y ese es un poco el código explicado como tal
las únicas cosas más que meterías lo que os decía probar a simplemente stop y tp limpios es decir
sin trailing y a nivel de filtro de volatilidad vale a nivel de filtro de volatilidad a mí me gusta
más que el de volumen pero también se puede probar el de volumen y ya está no no no hay mucho
no hay mucho más explorar estas ventanas y ya está se puede complicar lo que uno quiera se puede
complicar lo que uno quiera se puede también pues analizar hacer intermarkets comparado con
otro con otro futuro similar en este caso sería el nasdaq o lo que o lo que uno quiera se puede
hacer 250 cosas pero ya digo esto es básicamente lo que lo que es uno uno rb vale no tiene mucha
mucha historia mucha historia más vale vamos a ver ahora vamos a ver qué hora es ahora vamos a
hacer un pequeño descanso no vamos a aprovechar ahora para hacer el descanso y luego os voy
subiendo el material vale así que siempre son las ocho ya las ocho casi vamos a hacer un pequeño
descanso de como siempre unos cinco minutitos unos cinco de unos cinco minutitos y bueno 56
como a lo largo de un minuto o dos a las ocho como mucho estamos ya otra vez aquí hablando en casa
ahora pongo la la pausa la grabación y ahora os veo hasta ahora ya estaba aquí hablando sólo
hablando sólo porque pues nada esto es marca de la casa primero me doy cuenta de que no que tengo
el micro silenciado y es siempre otra vez hablar los da que tenía también silenciado el go to
web en así que dos dos veces dos veces silenciado a ver grabando si cámara aquí ahí estamos
ahí estamos vale entiendo que todo el mundo ya tiene el paper este os voy ahora a subir
vale los que os he comentado ha comentado como puedo ir sólo puedo meter ahora todos
puedo meter sólo hasta cinco voy a dejar más no ya no me dejas quito quito el que había antes
vale quito el que había antes a la una quito el curso rb2 a las dos quito el curso rb2 a las
tres vale con lo cual ya tengo 5 6 7 y 8 meto el 5 por orden 1 2 3 4 5 porque todos los artículos
que había de esta serie que os decía de krabbel pues los hemos montado ahí para que quites un
ejemplo vale jugando con la ruptura del rango de apertura los dos lo hemos traducido y así
pues lo podéis tener vale que es interesante porque digo la revista original no podemos
pero bueno pues así hemos hecho un apaño es ahí con nuestro paper nuestro logo y todo y aunque
sí que hemos pegado hasta las imágenes no creo que se no es que no igual se nota un poco no pero
son imágenes propias las hemos hecho todas nosotros caros son gráficos del siglo 14
estos artículos son súper antiguos para mí es que me encanta explorar estas ideas me encanta
esta o sea que tan antigua no sé pero pues está creo que está hecho en el 80 y largos 90
y bueno pues ahí está ahí está a veros borro borro 1 y meto 6 y voy así vale los habéis bajado
ya lo sabéis los estáis bajando todos atención lo voy a meter en el disco pero que los que no
me caben todos vale tengo que ir quitando venga y todo el 1 a la 1 quito el 2 a las 2 quito el
1 a 3 y ahora va el 6 y ahora sigo quito el 2 a la 1 quito el 2 a las 2 y quito el 3 ahí el 2 a las 3
y ahí va el 7 y vamos con el último sé que voy a quitar el 3 a la 1 3 a las 2 3 a las 3
estos son los documentos de esta serie que hizo krabbel en esto con commodity hace muchísimos
años pero es realmente interesante porque es una de las personas que más se considera ha trabajado
muchos años es muy interesante trabajar cosas así antiguas vale bien bueno mientras estaba
aquí dándole un poquito sacándole humo al optimizador vale para ver si a ver qué tal
hecho lo tengo ahí trabajando porque veo que aguanta bien ahora es que me parece que
dejé el procesador capado no lo dejé pero que sí que va que va estoy aquí a tope
del goto webinar ese es dios es impresionante me está aquí aguantando el directo grabando con
el con el de este aquí dios maravilla es un mérito esto bueno el goto webinar y el equipo
también entiendo que tendrán algo que decir pero es que está ahí fíjate está 91 pero va
aguantando dos a que pocos recursos gastan es increíble es que luego los vídeos verdad que
se vende maravilla es realmente queda muy bien bueno veremos este como se ve como se
vale tengo una idea el dax acabando que es es bastante larga pero pero la he puesto que
pare antes simplemente para mirarme les estoy guardando 8.000 justamente porque el fin de
semana estaba haciendo trabajando para el mapa de apolo y se ha quedado ahí configurado en 8.000
se ha quedado configurado en 8.000 pero vaya en cualquier momento va a acabar porque porque
ya os digo que que para en 15 entonces o que acaba de mejorar en 2 mil y pico cada vez saltaron
así cuando para 15 o 10 a ver qué hemos encontrado por aquí era puesto un poquito de filtro no sé
por qué me lo me lo leo que en el dax se pondría un poco el dax baje mucho baje mucho si si además
haber ordenado por esto tiene muy pocos tres no esto de que tengo yo aquí no no que va a
tirar muchos tres que es raro no parece bastante descompensada si es ese muy bajos era muchas
comisiones además alberto nosotros le metemos un tique entero creo bueno igual al dax no le
puesto un tique entero 12 medio tic no no no que coño un tico un tic es un tico no es un tic
0.50 si si es un tique es un tique es un tique es un tique 0.50 pero 25 no va a punto tío el
dax no no el que va a medios el mini tío el mini va medio si va a punto entero a punto entero pues
pues no todos hemos metido medio ya está bien yo creo es curioso como bueno es que al no
pararla o sea no dejarla parar pues realmente es muy volátil o sea tiene está muy dispersa
todavía realmente no no ha centrado nada no ha centrado nada a ver que voy a ver algunos
dos de 2004 no lo tengo sé las maneras como es más volátil que el que el dax hay que de cp
pues sí que aunque sigue siendo una curva súper loca pues sí que tiene algo algo mejor en aquí
realmente es lo que lo estaba comentando y de hecho podemos podemos hacerlo en un momento alberto
porque realmente no es nada nada complicado le podíamos meter esto ptp porque yo creo que
va a ir que va a ir bastante mejor en lo hacemos igual que con el tráiler configurado así dejo
el tráiler inquieto vale y así ya lo dejamos hecho para dejarlo trabajado para el fin de semana
ahí para el lunes que viene hoy de aquí dos días a 51 años vamos a ver qué son años pero
estoy con chavales no sé escribir pero se ha hecho la forma la forma máquina voy a meter aquí mismo
donde está el tráiler lo meto con 7 stop loss y hasta alberto no lo hago igual igual que
el otro y esto si es verdad tengo lo tengo un blog entero aquí se lo voy a copiar y
esto además le la varía igual la variable y no más rápido ese sí ya lo sé en este lo
teníamos aquí es que lo lo lo metí aquí antes alberto y luego lo borré no sé por qué porque
no te los explicar por qué lo metí luego lo que pasa que no me hace falta este he borrado el
mar que positivo porque ya lo llevo arriba este es este este es este este es el de arriba
a tomar viento me dejaba uno pero vengo de arriba o con este en del 6 ahí está pues nada ahí está
si es cero vale vale vale vale con el close pues venga ahora está recargando el código alberto
baneame abril y hazme el favor el favor de permanente permaban esos que no no pueden
entrar ya más gracias yo estoy contento de cumplir años de verdad no digo en serio no lo
digo por esto el otro es mirar este sábado estuvo en un cumple de 50 de otro amigo que
también sacó pero había otro que los hacía tan breve estaba hecho polvo digo pero tío de verdad
poder que es que drama los 50 oye pues que nos cumple una manera que es fácil no los cumples
si quieres tú nos cumples yo estoy contento de cumplir años de verdad la alternativa es
mucho peor sabes entonces la alternativa es mucho peor aurelis eso piénsalo alternativa es mucho
peor así que oye contento tú vamos para adelante es lo que hay esto se me ha jodido ahora o qué
pasa no tantos no a bueno 2004 20 20 para bueno estamos emitiendo supongo ahora lo que voy a
hacer es dejarle le voy a quitar el que le he puesto una hora este le he puesto sólo 10 20 30
40 50 he puesto una hora de análisis y con el típico el price de 9 a 10 que analice ahí y ahí
tiene el franquito vale aquí le dejo precio entrada la tendencia no la ha querido pero se la ahora con
el filtro se la voy a meter a meter por si no me va a tener muy pocos combinaciones de filtro
neve lo dejo el trailing me lo petó y le optimizamos el stilte el esto que le ponemos
y medio con mucho como tenemos muchos trades le granulo bien esto sólo para probar habría que
hacerlo con un poquito más de análisis que ahora pero es que no sé por qué me da la sensación que
va a mejorar bastante ahora me la puedo comer con patatas pero termina en 15 esa mañana me toca a
las 8 cojo un tren para madrid chicos o sea que me toca me toca para ir por mañana ya lo he visto
ya mañana tengo un viaje relámpago a madrid que voy a ver a mi buen amigo ivan sherman una reunión
de trabajo y no no no voy voy a ver el tema de trabajo y vuelvo el mismo día hoy como con él
hablamos un rato y para casa otra vez hay que celebrar los 51 que yo los voy a celebrar hoy
aunque con tu permiso con tu permiso los celebro aurelí me ha dado el pésame antes de todo esta
broma viene por ahí es que me ha hecho mi más sincero pésame pero 51 como estamos la
madre que no me ha hecho recordar el amigo este de verdad está hundido no es broma estaba de verdad
hundido o sea el tío 50 pero no sé si es curioso gente que lleva más lo de la edad que lleva bien
a ver qué tal a qué tal a esto pero de mientras vamos haciendo otra cosa sí
en noviembre el 73 bueno bueno todo lo que es el 73 es buena es buena pues nada mañana es a ver
si no hubiera si no tuviera el cumple pues igual a lo mejor hubiera alargado un poco pero pero ya
digo ha sido por esta reunión que la teníamos ya pendiente de cuando nos vimos en ranquia para
la entrega de premios del auditado que estábamos los dos con otro compañero los tres nominados
y se llevó el primer van muy merecido de hecho un año de locos y y bueno pues se charlamos y
tal pues quedamos en vernos en estos tres primeros meses del año y miramos se ha dado se ha dado que
que sea mañana que sea mañana así que ya digo voy nada comer y vuelta ojo la ve y otra vez
para para vuelta porque la verdad que hay mucho trabajo mucho trabajo hay mucho trabajo no nos
quejamos porque nos quejamos pero pero ya os lo he comentado que la verdad que el curso es un
esfuerzo bastante grande o sea ya a ver ya vamos de culo sin el curso hay que decir que ya sé
ya iríamos de culo igual pero por eso digo ya por cierto ya lo bueno ya lo creo que lo solté en
la teoría pero lo he hecho en algún directo he hecho en algún directo pero ya lo suelto aquí
primicia para los que estáis ahora en los que lo oiréis después que no tardaremos en convocar
un puesto de trabajo para ser sean sistemas y pues lógicamente estará todo el mundo que quiera
optar a él pues está en su derecho lógicamente de acuerdo y literalmente al
que se haciendo el curso y que realmente posee este aprendiendo cómo hacemos las
cosas pues pues es algo a valorar también cuando salgo salgo valorar no únicamente pero sí que es
algo algo valorar pero bueno ya cuando cuando se haga público podemos decir y se formalizaba
está mi cabeza de momento está mi cabeza pero pero está mi cabeza firmemente y las últimas
fechas lo pensó mucho porque realmente es que no vamos muy muy de culo no hay manera
no hay manera de cubrir todo y y hay que quedar más a quedar más así que no tardaremos en eso
así que ya ya os avisaré para que el que quiera no a ver preferiblemente presencial eso también
os lo digo porque no lo digo cerrado al cien por cien pero suma mucho suma muchísimo para mí el
hecho de que de que sea presencial o sea que pueda ser aquí en la oficina en rebus porque para mí
aunque ya sé que siempre es tecnológica que puedes trabajar ahí está hacia todo lo que quieras pero
yo trabajar el poder hablar aquí personalmente sabes a mí me aporta mucho me aporta mucho y
y realmente no lo descarto porque puede haber casos que digas oye pues mira vale la pena y
pueden haber excepciones a todos la vida no pero pero ya digo que principio principio se valorará
muy positivamente que sea presencial por alberto pues tenías razón en esto no acaba si si puede
aspirar al mundo de hecho estoy abierto a los a los dos tipos de sayola la voy a convocar en
los dos perfiles porque si todo va bien probablemente no de entrada pero probablemente en en meses puede
ser que que entremos a los dos perfiles de acuerdo por lo tanto estoy abierto a tal a los dos decir
a un junior y a un señor perfil alguien más que esté verde que tenga que aprender mucho mucho que
ya venga muy formado y pueda aportar mucho ya desde el primer día entonces los dos los dos
perfiles lógicamente pues más caro el señor es más caro es lo que tiene es lo que tiene entonces
hay que ver hay que ver un poco todo hay que ver un poco todo pero si si es un poco la idea
que llevamos no sé si habéis visto los los powerbom ahora ha quedado con el con el con el
esto puesto ya lo habéis visto esto no tiene no tiene nada es decir fijaros que es muy similar
al trailing al final que hace el trailing fijaros vale el trailing en la situación que tú estás largo
va tomando el valor más alto para el largo entre el trailing que ya tiene calculado el valor que ya
tiene calculado de la barra anterior vale o el máximo menos el máximo por un porcentaje
es decir si el precio ha subido más actualiza el valor si no ha subido más se mantiene el anterior
eso es tan fácil como un trailing ya está lo lanza a la siguiente barra al precio trailing
esto en cambio el stop es muy similar como tres sesiones tiene una palabra para hacer eso pues
la usas vale simplemente tienes que es el precio de entrada porque también tiene una palabra que ya
te lo permito referenciar simplemente te lo facilita pero si no pues se podría hacer cada
guardando el precio en otra plataforma pues lo podrías hacer guardando el precio de compra
por porcentaje de esto partido por cien por tipo en vale es el valor del punto en este caso en el
daix 20 y hasta este truquito que os he enseñado antes que es bueno simplemente si es mayor que
cero entra aquí si no es mayor que cero pues ya no entra no entra aquí y esto es para la vela de
entrada porque aunque se te estobló si lo hubiéramos puesto fuera de este bucle hubiera ido por
un tema de actualización de variables y tal pues es un poco mejor más seguro meterlo aquí pero
podrías haberlo hecho directamente fuera a piñón que en todas las velas lo tirara en tres sesiones
no se puede hacer porque el motor el easy language ya gestiona las órdenes no pone dos sabes en otros
lenguajes tienes que gestionar tú las órdenes aquí no aquí si le tiras tres órdenes el pone
la más cercana sabes y no genera problemas eso en teoría bueno va a acabar de un momento a otro
que está el mejor ahora 0 7 y 11 de tp esto más cercano y tp un poco más alejado es decir más bien
dejando correr la tendencia más tendencial que antitenencial normalmente en una antitenencial
sale más bien al revés en un tendencial suele ser un poco más cuando hay tendencia que decir
el hombre capto deja de ser como os he dicho un tendencial poco capado no acabó pero digamos que
sale relativamente coherente con eso bien y aquí veremos ahora un vistazo rápido pues que que
tenemos vale entrar a mirarnos antes no lo he enseñado pero si ya que le he hecho tal vamos
a mirar si tú miras en sample ya veis que el mejor en sample todos están dando rebundes más bien
negativos te están dando rebundes más bien negativos hay que ver porque no hemos mirado esto
antes ya sabéis que me gusta os lo expliqué cortar mirar bien donde corta el 70 al 30 es decir hay
que ver dónde corta el histórico vale porque a veces vemos que casualmente cortamos en una
zona donde es súper negativo para para el sistema entonces tiene una clara desventaja cuando hay
muchos straight es lo que os digo es verdad que se facilita pero cuidado no pensemos porque hay
muchos trades pero tampoco hay tantos no aquí no con este nivel de trades tampoco podemos
optimizar los ocho parámetros y quedarnos tan anchos es decir hay que ir poco a poco lo que
decía validando cada variable ver mapas etcétera pero al final claro aquí hay una cosa que no está
correcta porque hemos guardado 8000 entonces claro entre los 8000 hay combinaciones no no está bien
pero ya digo simplemente es para ver un poco el potencial del sistema esto no estamos viendo una
optimización bien hecha al uso sino simplemente ver el potencial del sistema a ver qué capacidades
nos nos ofrece no y bueno pues así que además hemos bloqueado la hora de entrada la hora de
salida no hemos elegido una y está sin más bueno sí da la sensación de ir algo mejor no alberto
algo mejor 1 10 nos ha quedado ahora tampoco es una gran mejora pero sí da la sensación de ir
algo mejor que antes habría que valer a ver ya digo no está ni tan solo le hemos dejado madurar y
habría que primero mirar las entradas trabajarlas bien además en el dax hay bastante trabajo porque
habría que mirar lo que os digo no primero mirar un poco si valorar el histórico lo que os decía
que trataremos de hacerlo un poco no es ir a hacer una una optimización tratando de usar también el
premarket sin usarlo ahora está sin usarlo ahora está directamente abriendo en horario lo que
nosotros llamamos horario regular que es que es eso el equivalente con la con el contado vale es decir
de 9 a 5 y media porque porque aquí es cuando hay más volumen es cuando hay más volumen y es donde
suele no suele cortarse más el bacalao no pero bueno es verdad que en un rb puede tener sentido
a lo mejor te evaluar evaluar evaluar también ese premarket además curiosamente es bastante
simétrico en el largo que en el corto si además a mí la hora del dax que quiero la he trucado
la he trucado pero es verdad que empezando a probar una cosa vamos a ir muy muy fuerte es
decir empezar muy pronto es que le vamos a dejar sólo tres velitas tres velitas de margen
tres velitas de margen y le vamos a salir a las 12 aquí ya vamos a otra cosa mariposa y le voy
a quitar todos los filtros le voy a dejar esto ptp momento lo optimizo que quiero verlo así
pero le pasaremos el optimizador va de puta madre acá en la cosita fina pero hecho tp aquí
que no sale la noticia las dos vamos a pasar hasta la una 10 20 30 0 salen 30 las velas recuerdo
por si alguien se ha apuntado tarde que tenéis ahí los unos cuantos papers del de krabbel que
os lo os pondré el discord de hecho voy a poner ahora mientras acaba esto y una feta no
fada storm que decimos en catalán como sería la traducción de casillano este refrán los
refranes me gusta mucho tras cambiarlos de lengua para cambiar mucho es una pasada cada
lengua tiene un poco sus refranes como es este alberto casillano feina feta no fada storm
a ver si alguien del chat se sabe que viene a decir pues que hacer las cosas bien nunca
nunca está mal nunca está mal material del curso de momento meto el urb que hemos metido ahora
los dejo los documentos hemos entregado en la clase del 4 de marzo del 2021 los puedo
gastar todos ahí creo no a esta vaina feta con seidad está está está de donde es sergio
una feta con seidad está que será de valencia vez la verdad me sonaba en una feta con seidad
faena hecha no molesta pero faena hecha no molesta y lo habido como vada van vada van
valencia lo que vada van vada van esa me gusta bueno y aprovechaba para subir esto al disco
bueno les resiguió mucho la hora ahora él resiguió mucho la hora quería probar justamente eso de
obligarlo a salir antes de la del mercado americano tienes dejarlo muy centrado en es que igual igual
para hacer eso yo creo que deberías de ir muy más a una en un minuto igual o sabes a saco
o sea para pillar el movimiento de volatilidad y ya no te digo la una igual hasta las 10 sabes
tratar de pillar cinco minutos son muy que bien es que hay un revés super que van así en eso
creo que en el paper lo explica es decir os lo dije la semana pasada son los revés como más de
oportunidades muy concretas no porque es muy distinto a esto es decir cosas pero ahí yo lo
buscaría todavía en timeframes más cortos y en ventanas muy cortas o sea explorar ventanas de
mercado muy muy estrechas porque activos que lo tienen y el el dax por ejemplo que os decía
la acción de ventanas bastante definidas que es verdad que ahora llevo unos años sin operarlo
pero sí que lo había operado mucho el dax y si es muy es muy muy muy movido la que es rápido
parado que le he puesto en 10 habrá madurado nada habrá controlada será un churro que no
le hemos dado tiempo bueno aún encara pero no le hemos dado tiempo 137 coño y tan mal
pues el mejor que hemos sacado es el mejor que hemos sacado con 6.300 esto es esto le falta
el lift alberto claro hombre claro a tal y te estampa esto era el esto muy muy pegado es nada
no es que nada es nada que no tiene él y no lo he puesto porque no ajustaba tanto los estados
pero los he ajustado no me ha acordado si si ahora verán le pongo el libro y veréis si si si ahora
veréis ahora veréis ahora veréis ahora veréis en que se queda la curva ahora veréis cuando llega
la fucking realidad bueno y en un minuto cuidado porque estando en 10 bueno yo creo que sí sí para
aquí es poco pero pero yo creo que le va a dar le va a dar para que no hay que dejarlo
tanto nada más con esto si ahora lo subo y está que valor tenía aquí tanto no tanto no tanto no
va a estar lo tanto 135 veréis en que hay que escribir un 35 35 ya no sería más con este
nivel de operaciones mira habéis visto la realidad es un buen ejemplo de lo que supone la realidad
sin querer sin querer que la teórica os dije os enseñé alguno que estaba forzado pues mirar
sin forzar me ha salido sin querer pero esto porque yo lo he visto ya rápido porque ya por
la experiencia lo ves pero pero hay que vigilar que vigilar es 001 nada eso es mentira eso es
mentira incluso así podría ser mentira incluso así puede ser mentira pero bueno ya yo creo que
ya viendo que con 001 no sale no sale bien sin filtros
me está llamando para probarle más a ver a ver el horario como ha cerrado los que ha dejado
correr alguno no ha dejado correr ninguno es que no le es que con un no antes lo has visto antes
aquí este este que ahora tenía un estudio de máximos y mínimos pero no me acuerdo me parece
que es de muchos años pero si lo encuentro no te acordas para qué revista lo hice verdad
oberto hice un estudio de máximos el que lo hice con el con el de este de con el sobre de
calma y que esto lo haremos aquí ya lo haremos aquí pero ahora me ha acordado de gober si
veo veo en que no lo veo esto que ahora está excelli eso para esto venía muy bien esto esto
cuando lo hagamos lo veréis para este tipo de sistemas sino muy bien porque es es un código que
te permite analizar lo que pues yo que sé en qué en qué hora se hace máximos en que hora se hace
mínimos y sacas un histograma la mar de apañado pero se hace muchísimos años que lo dice que no
estaría actualizado pero pero sería chulo verlo no es para esto viene viene bien es la verdad que
el access muchos los hacen la apertura y otros en la pero sí que me parece recordar que en esa
frontera 12 1 es aquí tenía bastante frecuentemente puntos de inflexión entonces pues por eso os digo
hay que trabajar y ahí puedes ver a lo mejor ventanas que a lo mejor es usted es que
realmente era muy estrecha de 10 a 12 voy a tratar de buscarla esa entonces te buscas ya un
sistema para ese mercado y eso es extremadamente útil y funciona muy bien funciona muy bien pero
ya no no este sistema digo mejor un mil reversión o sea pero muy concreto en una hora muy concreta
y hay activos que les pasa es lo que las divisas les pasa mucho y esto con este tipo de activos
con este tipo de que esto que lo puedes hacer con cualquier activo en el final
simplemente busca a qué horas hace hace máximos y ya está pero van a esto ya te digo está está
justo lo voy a probar más forzado ahora que ya tenemos el lift ahora que también va a tardar más
claro ya vengo el iba a tardar más a ver todo no pero si es igual se acaba parando el todo se acaba
parando igual al final para el final para el final para para el lunes que viene
cerraremos este y haremos breakout de que no sea rv haremos este con presentando alguna versión
más aprovechable está espero que para el taxi no para el sb o el nasdaq pero presentaremos
una versión aprovechable y a partir de a partir de ahí pues haremos a algún otro por la trinity
breakout de este tipo pero no no tan centrado en el opening ya tengo de hecho por ahí alguno
y os recomiendo que os leáis todo esto de claro que me voy a ver a ser muy antiguos es
curioso como lo hacía él no porque él no era bien bien un rango no sino sentado mucho la apertura y
mucha comparativa de con las velas anteriores de lo que había pasado antes no de lo que había
pasado antes porque al final esto define mucho a los rv es el fin de mucho la sorpresa y bueno
básicamente haremos eso haremos eso y no os preocupéis que me comprometo a enseñaros lo que
no sé si todo lo que evidentemente evidentemente todo no pero todo es parte de este de ese trabajo
estamos probando un software un software nuevo de wall forward ya lo tenemos que tal
externo y a ver qué a ver qué por por el tema de velocidad y lo que decía de capacidad porque
el de montechas a mí no me acaba de gustar mucho y el de el de tres sesiones que es lo que decía
es que es lentísimo ya no es que es lentísimo es que no no acepta o sea por ejemplo una opti de
cincuenta mil combinaciones en exhaustiva o de cuarenta mil no la no las puede hacer
depende que no las puede hacer se rompe o sea porque como no acepta lo cuántos son tres gigas
abertos 64 bits creo o 32 bits o dos gigas bueno hay un límite de archivos si pero parece que no
acepta archivos de más de que no sé cuántas gigas y bueno pues eso me parece que son dos mira
pero hablo de memoria y entonces pues como genera un archivo de más de dos gigas de tres pues el
problema es revienta en cambio este programa pues no es lo que lo que os digo al final no sé
por qué están evolucionando muy poco el software a lo mejor les va muy bien en con el tema
discusional que apenas se centra en aspecto gráfico y demás no sé porque al final todas
estas empresas acaban viviendo la mayoría del brokeraje todas acaban igual la única que se
mantiene que no de momento es multicharts pero pero ninja también se la pilló un broker web lab en su
momento la compró fidelity es que al final todas acaban igual en el momento estamos probando el
software y a lo largo del año confío también en probar el de web lab porque como se vea que
va bien y pueda más o menos integrarlo para lo que hacemos pues igual nos pasamos a web lab
para a nivel de análisis y backtest digo sobre todo una plataforma realmente muy muy guapa en su
momento vale y ahora cuando acabemos esto lo lo iremos sacando por hoy a ver si si me acaba esto
apretito mientras hoy pues hemos empezado el mes en se los analfa a tope acabamos mal febrero y
hoy viene el mercado subiendo no entiendo estamos haciendo máximos el día ahora
pero mucho loro mira los mercados hoy mirar como la vida del teo y lo colomico
no he mirado ni como va la bolsa hoy es el oro por cierto noticia de noticia importante
para aquellos que seguíes internet hoy anuncian los box adores de la velada 4
que lo sepáis noticia importante autos memory error bueno esto está probablemente es fruto de
la hora me pasó el fin de semana cuando se satura mucho el pc ya está ya no puede cuando sé ahora
ya no ya no hay nada que hacer o sea ya pues que si ahora vuelves a optimizar pasa lo mismo hay
que cerrarla asegurarte que se han cerrado los procesos todos los procesos y ya está y nada
tienes que venir aquí a su hora te que se ha cerrado todo cuando os pase eso una vez se cuelguen
es que ven aquí ahora no o sea porque está abierta no pero cuando la cierres ver que aquí
esto y esto que se les lengua warehouse se cierra y todo lo que es el sexo y esto te
se rete a server que también está el sexo bueno pues nada hoy acabamos un poquito antes y ya
lo recuperaremos que habrá tiempo no se ocupeis y os voy a ir ya dejando hasta el lunes que viene
donde como os digo acabaremos el revés y con total seguridad empezaremos otra estrategia ya digo
que esta o muy parecida a esta trataremos de presentar una muy parecida a esta que sea algo
aprovechable vale que es aprovechable y ya explicaremos un poco lo que he dicho trataremos
de tenerlo bastante avanzado que lo enseñaremos aquí pero tendremos de tenerlo avanzado porque
si no es imposible por tiempo pero porque ya veis vete por esa que optimizar un poco
se te va se te va la hora en un momento entonces trataremos de tenerlo hecho y veremos a ver
lo explicando paso a paso pero como os digo primero entradas filtros salidas de acuerdo
así que nada más familia hasta el lunes que viene a ver espera espera que siempre lo digo
lo tengo que poner luego se me olvida así así ahora sí ahora sí hasta el lunes chao